so i just got done with round eight of
the abu dhabi masters tournament
and as usual uh it's dinner time so i
try and keep this as brief as possible
but it was a really fun game and i got
to use an opening
which i've been preparing for the last
month to two months
that i've never played before in an
over-the-board classical game
so i was playing a young player fm almar
atakashiev
from azerbaijan
and i was expecting him to play the
catalan
which is very popular opening these days
and i opted for a line in this position
which
is super super rare if you see the
masters database
uh i played
one of the most rare moves here pawn h6
yeah this is a line i
i've seen played a handful of times it's
been played in like the
uh what was it the summer classic at st
louis chess club
by jj ali morandi
and there's been a few other players
that have been using this line actually
including magnus carlsen uh magnus won a
really nice game against laquan liam
and the point of h6 is to remain
flexible but to also employ a setup with
bishop d6
and then if white were to play knight c3
here the plan is to play knight c6
and then
usually black goes for takes and a quick
e5
and h6 is useful in preventing bishop g5
so the main line is b3 takes takes an e5
and this is a game between magnus and
laquan miyam uh magnus playing black uh
one won a nice game
equalized pretty easily and then a
ground down end game
so we didn't quite go into this
and i'll admit that i didn't do too much
specific preparation
for my opponent because i couldn't find
any games where he played against this
line so i wasn't entirely sure what to
expect but we did get this position and
he played the move queen c2 which is one
of the options for white it depends upon
and then rather than playing knight c6
and going for the same plan
uh i go for a slightly different plan as
b6 just to
very solidly complete development with
bishop b7 and knight d7
and that's essentially what happened
we both complete development
and then very soon
there became a lot of pawn tension in
the center
and no one really wanted to relieve the
tension
the pawn stayed like this for the next
few moves after rook c1 queen e7 queen
b1
rook d8
yeah it was very tense position
um i was still trying to move quickly
like even though this wasn't specific
preparation
uh the move seemed very natural
and
maybe one alternative was to take on d4
but after knight takes d4
the move i want to play is e5 but that
runs into knight five and also have to
watch out for knight b5 bishop b8 bishop
a3 ideas
so i really didn't want to relieve the
tension because i think either capture
helps blade improve
so finally my opponent took a pawn on d5
i take back
and then e3 was played so structure
transforms a little bit
i play queen e6 nice move improving the
queen i was anticipating some
like eventual knight h4 to f5 idea and
actually
after queen e6 my opponent did play
knight h4 so now the queen is a bit
better placed on e6 where it's not a
target
of knight f5
and
i think this move may have been a small
mistake uh just because of my next move
knight e4
but the position just gets really sharp
and i wasn't entirely sure what exactly
is going on
but here my opponent took a super super
long think
and eventually played
knight takes e4 we can see the
timestamps are accurate so
from an hour and one minute down to 38
minutes
and um
when i played 94 i was aware that
my opponent could go for this line after
takes he played d5
and this is a
pawn sacrifice
and
i didn't think it was so dangerous at
first but uh it turned out to be
a bit tricky because after bishop takes
d5
it looks like i have everything under
control
but
he has a really resourceful move bishop
h3
deflecting my queen
away from defending my bishop i'm
essentially forced to take on h3 and
after rook d5 uh there are definitely
some problems to solve for black given
that this pawn is hanging the bishop's
hanging
and white has a lot of pressure from
various directions
so things seemed a little bit unstable
but next few moves i just try and
consolidate brought the queen back to
defend everything
rook d1 and bishop to c7
and then after knight f5 i play f6
i had to just obstruct the the diagonal
uh maybe there was some alternative here
although i think f6 is pretty much
forced because if knight f6
then
what was i scared of i think just bishop
f6
and ah yeah there's a funny trick that
if takes takes takes
uh this just loses for black because of
the the triple fork
so
i play f6
trying to blunt the power of the bishop
and then my opponent plays knight d6
and
i think this is just a
liquidating move i essentially have to
take and after takes queen to e7 i'm
still up a pawn but after queen c2
white is ready to play queen d2
forming the triple battery on the d-file
and i didn't see anything better
other than to give back the pawn and
just to neutralize everything i played
that f8 we trade rooks
uh all the rooks come off the board and
then queen takes e4
um and finally the dust has settled and
we're in a relatively quiet
end game but still imbalanced it's uh
it's queen and knight versus queen and
bishop
i have the queen side majority which is
maybe some
small edge for black because i can more
easily create a past pawn
and generally queen and knight just are
working better together over queen and
bishop
so i thought i still have some winning
chances here
and uh yeah around here my opponent
offered me a draw but
i figured there's no risk in playing on
just made simple improving moves king f7
uh and then he plays b4 which uh i think
is trying to force matters to
um get rid of my my c5 pawn so maybe the
bishop can access d4
i take he takes and i play a5
so i'm trying to
eventually make a pass pawn on the queen
side but after bishop c3 knight c5 queen
c4 check queen e6
i would have been really happy with the
queen trade here
uh even though
i'd
lose the queen and knight versus queen
and bishop
and balance
uh this would just lead to an end game
where i think black is really close to
winning because my king is much closer
to the action
and uh the pawns are ready to march down
and white has really no active play
against these
pawns on the king side
so
he avoided the queen trade and played
queen to b5
and this is where i took a very long
think trying to figure out
the
the move that gives me the most chances
in the position
initially what i wanted to do was to
take the apon
uh and allow this trade
but i don't think this leads to much for
black and i also have to be careful like
i wanted to go for a move like 94 but
this just loses a knight due to the
double attack
and then if knight d3
white has all these annoying checks
and
this might also be losing for black
not entirely sure but
like if check
or king of fate check and then queen g7
might be coming this might lead to a
draw somehow like some weird perpetual
so i am threatening to take on f2 but i
didn't want to go into that line
and
there was another move i was looking at
after queen b5
but my brain is kind of just mashed
potatoes right now
which actually sounds kind of appetizing
so uh let's see what's what ended up
happening i played team to g6
um trying to
run away from the potential checks
and then uh this allowed bishop takes a5
uh my opponent was getting pretty low on
time and we got into this ending the
minor pieces came off the board i played
queen takes a2
and now we're in a position where it's
still equal pawns but i'm still the one
playing for a win because i have the
outside passer
and it's a question can white somehow
force perpetual and the answer is no
after check
king 2h7 czech king h8
after queen c8 i have the very nice move
queen g8 and i avoid the perpetual
but the problem is my queen gets really
passive and after queen c6
it's really hard to actually advance
advanced a pawn
and
i mean ideally i want to get the queen
to b4 but then white will start having
more annoying checks so i started with
queen b8
and after king g2
queen e5 centralizing the queen
defending the pawn attacking white's
pawn controlling e8s so i thought this
was a nice square for the queen but
after g4
uh it was just really hard to make
progress
and i played the only
idea in the position that i could find
was queen
to g5 hitting the pawn but my opponent
very simply plays f3
and uh this just offers a trade if uh if
takes on e3 then white's gonna win the a
pawn and this would just be a draw
so
um i decided to go back to e5
but then after queen c8
king h7 white just has uh basically a
perpetual check uh there's no escaping
the checks and if i do try and escape
then white's going to win the pawn and
didn't see anything better than to
repeat
i was considering f5 but i think this is
just not necessary if f5 just takes and
i don't see how black can play for a win
here
so i played king hh offered to draw and
my opponent accepted
and that was round eight um
an interesting game and i'm super
curious
what the engine thinks about this game
but i'm also super hungry so what i'm
gonna do is
leave a link to the leachat study where
i'm saving all my games and if you want
to analyze and see
[Music]
everything that was was done wrong this
game and see what stockfish thinks is
best
feel free to analyze on your own but
it's dinner time and there's a morning
round tomorrow at 10 a.m
it's currently after 9 p.m
so food and sleep is now the priority
goodbye